e eu sempre fui um sonhador
eu sempre pensei que um dia poderia
contar uma história da qual me
orgulhasse e do qual as pessoas também
se orgulhasse e desde pequena sempre
percebi que sonhar uma coisa que era
permitida a todos e eu gostaria muito
que vocês puderam assim sonhar sempre e
eu imagino assim os sonhos como universo
como as estrelas infinito
a gente pode escolher o que quiser e um
dia isso aqui já foi um sonho pra mim é
pequeno mas foi um sonho
a minha história começa em 2011 eu
tentei quatro vezes passar em medicina e
conseguir passar em 2011 talvez meu
maior meu melhor soja tenha se realizado
em 2011
eu nunca poderia imaginar as coisas que
eu iria encontrar medicina até porque
minha família não tem ninguém médico num
painel não tem pai médico não tem uma
mágica
provavelmente o mais próximo da área da
saúde que eu tenho uma tia que a
enfermeira mas lá dentro da minha cabeça
e eu sei que tem isso também na cabeça
de cada um de vocês
existe uma vozinha dizendo faz medicina
hoje eu chamo de talvez uma voz divina
que me empurra sem para medicina e
dentro de cada um de vocês existe uma
voz também que conduz vocês para um
determinado caminho você só precisam
ouvir
por mais que tivesse gerado todas as
perninhas minhas expectativas dentro do
curso de medicina em 2011 gera em 2012
quase um ano depois do curso eu já era
muito aplicado
gostava de anatomia e histologia e
embriologia
mas eu nunca poderia esperar que
acontecesse o que aconteceu em 2012
eu conheci uma clínica de oncologia em
belém ea clínica me abraçou e me mostrou
uma tv diferente
mateus empreendedor o mateus palestrante
manter organizado que não existia antes
em 2012 eu comecei uma série de projetos
dos quais nos quais eu vou mostrar pra
vocês
outubro rosa outubro rosa não é uma
campanha nossa é uma campanha mundial
que há um objetivo é alertar as mulheres
sobre o câncer de mama quem não sabe o
câncer de mama hoje no estado do pará é
o terceiro é que mais incidência que
mais acomete as mulheres o primeiro ao
câncer de pele não melanoma é o segundo
câncer de colo e essa campanha que é uma
campanha mundial a gente trouxe para o
estado ea gente fez diferente
essa é uma campanha teórica você vai lá
e alerta a mulher sobre os fatores de
risco sobre a importância do diagnóstico
precoce e nós fomos além
nós queríamos algo prático e nós criamos
mutirão da mama múltipla da mama já
atendeu mais de duas mil mulheres em
cinco anos eo nosso objetivo é dobrar
esse número na metade do tempo nesses
cinco anos aqui a equipe que organizou
já ocorreu em mais de quatro municípios
do estado
aqui são as mulheres atendido aqui
na época em 2014 a gente receber um
prêmio o prêmio top socioambiental e
aqui um outro evento que eu tenho
orgulho é enorme a gente qual é um mês
ante intervalo funcional de oncologia
aonde a gente reúne acadêmicos de
medicina acadêmicos de todas as áreas
saúde farmácia enfermagem e leva pra
eles um conteúdo de congresso diferente
um conteúdo diferenciado a gente tem
música ao vivo como ocorreu aqui é a
gente coloca os a gente tira essa
formalidade que apenas uma pessoa
falando a gente confronta os assuntos só
participando para poder entender o que é
o evento a equipe mas eu não vim aqui
falar pra vocês das coisas que eu fiz
até porque estaria vendendo algo errado
no papel ta ta outro tema e não vim
falar disso porque a minha vida mesmo
mudou em 2015 em 2015 uma frase que eu
gostaria que vocês ficarem se
perguntando ela até o final da
conferência
quanto vale uma vida pode ser em reais
pode ser euros pode em dólares pode ser
uma palavra pode ser um carinho
será que existe será que dá pra medir
quanto vale uma vida por aqui da comerso
o messi está entre 255 milhões e 280
milhões
isso a gente for uma escala último seria
o karim benzema do real madrid avaliado
em média 46 milhões de euros não é
então teoricamente a gente conseguiria
comprar uma pessoa conseguiria comprar o
messi o goleiro neymar e colocar no meu
time lá dada pela então vai ganhar mas
isso até órico daria para comprar o
problema aqui brasil colônia
dava pra comprar pessoas também é justo
um anúncio onde onde mostra um fugitivo
e tão pagando por essa pessoa é justo se
dá pra comprar o messi porque não dá pra
comprar um negro escravo tabela que é
fantástico de um artigo e ela mostra o
valor de pessoas além de escravos no
brasil colônia menores dividido por
faixa etária cor gênero e vocês terem
uma idéia um escravo no brasil colônia
custava em média 350 mil réis
transformar isso trazemos para reais não
dá é muito difícil os valores a gente
nunca vai conseguir ter um valor exato
então como é que a gente pode trabalhar
a gente pode trabalhar comparativamente
então por exemplo se eu pegar uma saca
de café no brasil colônia bahia cerca de
12 mil réis
então a gente dividir 350 mil reais por
12.000 rede vai dar 29,16 vamos
trabalhar com 30 sacas com 30 sacas de
café
a gente comprava uma pessoa para
trabalhar pra gente
escravo não receber nada mas ainda bem
que acho que a vida não termina por aqui
tornou disso é é contra isso que a gente
tem que lutar pessoas ainda trabalham
por valores ínfimos eu chamo de
escravidão não sei como você chama essas
peças de vidas vai vai esse dinheiro ele
já sabe
só que é um desenho esquemático
interessante
tem gente que acredita que a vida é
assim em uma planta nasce cresce e chega
no ap morre e depois tem nada eu eu
acredito que vocês acham que é diferente
imagina quanto carinho não existe entre
o nascimento eo crescimento de um pai e
de uma mãe por um filho
imagina em quanta coisa um ser humano
não consegue produzir que entre o
crescimento o ápice imagina quanta coisa
a gente não pode aprender entre o ápice
e uma morte com outras pessoas imagina
quanta coisa a gente não pode deixar
entre a morte e na crença que você
acreditasse vai ter vida depois ou não
eu não acredito só nessa trajetória sim
eu acredito e muito mais
eu sempre funcionando eu espero que
vocês sejam também sempre 2015 embora
voltar é 2015 foi foi sem dúvida o ano
da minha vida descoberta por um episódio
no curso de medicina existem dois
momentos quatro anos de curso aonde você
tem a divisão entre a parte teórica e
prática aonde a parte teórica é muito
mais abordada você estuda muito mais lê
muito mais do que atende pacientes e
nesse período de 24 anos você tem um
contato tem muito contato com o paciente
mas um contato com um paciente por vez e
em pouco tempo
então você atende o paciente hoje e vai
atender o paciente daqui três meses dois
meses ídolo é voltar a vê-lo no
internato
a situação muda a gente passa dois anos
no internato é como se a gente estivesse
internado dentro do hospital porque a
gente realmente mora no hospital ea
gente passa 30 dias com os pacientes 40
dias com o paciente então a gente
realmente conhece tem um paciente é a
gente sabe o nome completo que às vezes
a gente esquece de uma pessoa para outra
a gente sabe que ele tem filho a gente
sabe que tem muito a gente sabe que
música gosta a gente sabe que tipo de
quais são as pessoas que moram com ele
que pessoas vêm visitá los
qual o perfil de uma pessoa mas teve uma
pessoa mais alegre e no primeiro dia do
internacional devem estar se perguntando
que significa essas letras que a gente
quer se dirigir um paciente de uma
discussão clínica a gente usa iniciais
para preservá-lo do paciente
a minha paciente a partir de agora a
gente vai chamar de paciente a amd cpi
influenciar do nome dela eu conheci ela
no meu primeiro dia de internato
chega uma bancada o professor entrega um
prontuário para as equipes para a gente
poder ficar acompanhar aquele paciente
por 30 dias
e um dos colegas pegou um prontuário que
estava escrito
isso aqui não se preocupe com os temas
identificação senhora ncp sexo feminino
56 anos casadas religiosas revide
companheiros e filhos
a queixa principal é o que ela é que
incomoda olho amarelo dor de barriga ou
será aqui a nossa história e foi isso o
que houve
enquanto estava lendo meu prontuário de
outra paciente hd a história da doença
atual paciente relata que teria fixa
existente há cerca de cinco meses
associada com episódios já corria fecal
colúmbia e proibido generalizada refere
dor em pocono e flanco direito relata
episódios de náuseas e perda ponderal e
aproximadamente 20 quilos em cinco meses
eu passei cinco anos numa clínica de
oncologia
quando eu ouvi isso aqui automaticamente
a minha cabeça me reportou para essas
doenças
exceto a primeira as outras são câncer
então na hora eu briguei pela paciente
corre pedia por favor nunca caí
prontuário deixa eu ficar com ele pegue
aqui porque eu já conheço a doença
trabalhei muito tempo com isso você quer
me passar o prontuário ea partir daí eu
conheci a paciente a msp a paciente a
ela era totalmente diferente da dos
pacientes que tinham conhecido eu nunca
cheguei a uma vez no leito que ela
tivesse triste
sempre sorridente alegre nunca havia
reclamado de dores que ela sentia eu
nunca havia reclamado os protocolos
demoradas hospital e ela a ela me fazia
ir pra que todo dia encontra lá cedo uma
felicidade enorme
índio chegou a contar um episódio sobre
os índios chegou chorando eu tenho
corrido cheguei logo elas senhor ao que
as potências já tinha uma dor alguma
coisa ela disse não foi posto em uma
música da minha igreja e toda vez que
chove fica emocionado e eu pensando que
eu estava com dor
ela era fantástica fantástica dia 2 de
dezembro
a minha vida mudou aqui nesse dia foi o
dia que eu fui convidado protege e foi o
dia que eu encontrei lá uti depois da
cirurgia
e nesse dia eu queria registrar
exatamente o que eu estava sentindo
porque eu queria dividir com vocês e eu
escrevi uma carta no mesmo dia do
convite e eu queria ler pra você está
guardado aqui não abrir a grande piada
está guardada decidir
2 de dezembro de 2015
hoje sem dúvida é um dia típico recebi
de um grande amigo e um grande amigo um
convite ea responsabilidade de inspirar
pessoas que assim como eu acreditam que
os seres humanos possuem valor
inestimável
estou muito feliz por seguir pois sei
que todo o meu esforço durante esses
anos de curso não estão sendo
reconhecidos como disse hoje um dia
típico pela primeira vez na vida
experimento dois lados da moeda devido
verdadeira felicidade com verdadeira
tristeza estava em uma das visitas do
internato médico passando nos vejo ele
com o controle de infecções que está lá
conhecido como cch foi inevitável susto
alguma subia dos pés à cabeça
minha paciente estava em um dos leitos
vi de longe
sabia que ela tinha passado por uma
cirurgia mas não imaginava seu status
clínico pedir licença a preceptoria em
aproximar do eleitor
ela percebeu a aproximação de alguém e
pestanejou até conseguir abrir os olhos
o sorriso instantâneo estava preservado
mas não com o mesmo vigor a voz fraca e
sua prosa dava bom dia e com o movimento
de notável esforço aproximava a mão para
um cumprimento não podia tocá-la pelas
boas práticas de higiene e montei pela
primeira vez repito estava em um dia
típico durante aquele mesmo assim
melhorar nunca tinha visto ela nesse
estado
sempre sorridente com bom humor apesar
de doente dos protocolos burocrático e
demorado de hospitais no flash de luz
aquele um mês dando assistências e orar
me veio à mente o momento em que a
conhecer as primeiras primeiras
perguntas encontro matinal diário
repleto de alegria apesar do ambiente
hospitalar
eu gostaria de ter mais dias atípicos eu
gostaria que todos vocês tivessem
experimentar o dias atípicos como que o
como que eu tive hoje
não fala da experiência ruim mas seu
poder de transformação
vim poucos dias uma pessoa mudar
totalmente da euforia à apatia
talvez não saiba ainda o real valor de
uma vida
aliás quem disse que esse valor existe
mais mais uma certeza eu tenho as
pessoas são incríveis e independente do
sexo da etnia da religião da profissão
dos seus defeitos sempre algo que não
soma temos que dar valor a todos e
quando eu falo em valorização eu não
falo em elogios diários é simplesmente o
ato de perceber as pessoas e de se
interessar por elas
eu espero que o matheus aí do futuro
tenha aprendido a lição e que ele possa
passar com o mesmo carinho e entusiasmo
e felicidade com o qual escreve agora
desejo daqui do passado que todos vocês
aí no futuro saibam valorizar as pessoas
ao redor
o porteiro o médico advogado a diarista
os professores
todos são importantes deixo aqui uma
nova mensagem para o futuro
sempre que puderem volta a este momento
e aí está a palestra e se perguntem
quanto vale uma vida
quando me perguntarem no futuro ea
mensagem para o futuro do que eu mais
gostei no curso
eu vou dizer que foi dividir esse
momento com vocês
obrigado